So these are the data types in pythonia strings
text types numerical Etc.
A variable can be assigned to any one of these data
types.
Now we don't have this in Python. We have this in C++. There's a special
type of variable called The Pointer variable.
What is the point of variable do?
And in C++ when you declare this variable you put
a star next to it.
the pointer variable allows you to
get the address or assign a variable
to any address of anything in memory
in your program at least.
Why is this relevant?
Now you don't have this problem a python when C++ you do
whenever you create something in a C++
program that thing will take up space
in memory and if you are to reassign a variable.
To another piece of data, in fact declaring another
valuable. You're still creating a new piece of
data in memory, but the
ones to which you were pointing before are still there.
now
New C++ compilers have garbage collection. This is
taken care of but
You still need to be careful with?
when we later on when we work with
Graph data structures you need to be careful when you're declaring variables.
So for example, one of the things we want to do in binary tree
is rebalanced the binary tree.
and knowing what we're what our data
structure is doing to the temporary storage will allow us to implement
something like
You know an algorithm for rebalancing a binary tree.